kamala hearth is my vice president
i just want to let one out i want to
start my day i was holding it in i was
waiting for someone to bring it up i
wanted to do it on the show so we can
all do it together
everybody who's watching live right now
take a deep breath and one two three
let's get it out
one two three yeah
so [ __ ] here for it v's here before
she tweeted it celebrities are tweeting
it everyone's tweeting it i tweeted
that i made a joke uh saying that i
thought that kamala died
earlier in the week and people tell me
i'm racist because i made a wrestling
joke
um about a dead wrestler but then i saw
some of my other friends tweeting it and
they got love for it so i don't know
so who cares it doesn't matter the
world's on fire but
listen kamala harris joe biden congrats
i think it's
i think it's going to be a a very
promising ticket
but unfortunately it's not the winning
number
there's a lot of people in this country
i'm kidding i'm just kidding there's a
lot of people in this country who
probably thought madonna's religion
kabbalah won
yeah because yeah i mean is she does she
follow kabbalah is she
indian asian what is she who's claiming
her
what where is history being made because
it's the only thing i'm here for
kamala listen most likely because you
know you honestly joke around
but mostly democratic kids and i think
kamal harrison joe biden is obviously
kamal iris he's got an amazing um
political uh background you know uh
attorney general of california does
great things i think she was the right
pick for joe biden
um because i don't know here's my theory
i don't think joe biden is even gonna
make it to the election
i think he'll die before november and
then i think legally she becomes a
presidential candidate
so she'll be the president but also we
keep calling our african-american first
african-american vice president
her father's jamaican and her mother's
indian so she
is a person of color she's a poc she's
an aoc poc
yes she's but but she's not
african-american which i
which is okay it's okay that she's not
african-american
but i'm just i want to point that out
that she's not african-american
and um sean king's a big fan of hers
yeah as well
uh she's not an african-american neither
is elan omar
she won her primary against an
african-american
so it was an african-american who
conservatives wanted to win
white conservatives wanted to win and
then there was a muslim african
immigrant
that white liberals wanted to win so
i mean it was a real they both had
horses in the race
right and they both uh rose a lot of
how do you say risen rosemary how do you
raise money
jesus rose from the dead three days
after he died
he has risen but if you so that's jesus
but if you're rising money do you risen
money or road money or
rise you raised money raised money okay
i can't wait to watch all these
white [ __ ] celebrities start rolling
out their [ __ ]
let's pandering [ __ ] psychosis i
like kamala harris too
i really like kamala horace but i mean
shut up with the dolls
let's see i want to see this this is fun
so a lot of kids play
with yeah marvel characters
she's saying even when i look she's on
mute there it is
man hello madame vice president she
plays with superheroes
hello madam vice president yeah yeah
yeah right side of history yes that's
gonna get me more roles in movies
right side of history that's what she
that's why they do it you gotta
understand that's why they do it they
say this is what's gonna get me
booked so it's [ __ ] because here's
the truth
jessica chastain i guarantee you if i
was able to put a little [ __ ] nesting
cam over your shoulder in that voting
booth you're gonna go to the right
because you got a lot of money
and it's fun to just watch celebrities
lose their influence because whatever
they tweet nobody really cares anymore
people care about what taylor swift
tweets because she's huge
you're either massive or you're a
tick-tock star at this point
it's like bobby it's like ricky bobby
said you ain't first last
yeah nobody cares about those middle
actresses anymore nobody's checking in
to see what natalie portman's got to say
about the upcoming 2020 election people
want to know what [ __ ] logan paul's
got to say and they want to know what
taylor swift's got to say
but they're not really checking what
kerry washington has to say although she
did say
yes shout out natalie shout out natalie
portman from scioscia long island that
you got
did a good movie with the black swan we
really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild